all right well hello everyone this is 13
ways of
at a turtle my name is Scott volition I
have a website f-sharp fun and profit
calm and the slides and the video for
this talk will go on the turtle
subdirectory at some point I'm going to
be using f-sharp to all the code
examples but this is really a talk about
concepts so most of this stuff will work
in other programming languages
especially functional programming
languages Haskell and Scala and so on
all right so most talks are you know on
a particular topic and I thought why not
take one problem domain and show you
lots of different ways of solving the
same problem with different techniques
so it's like I sort of taste the menu so
I'm going to be talking about a lot of
functional mostly functional programming
techniques partial application
functional error handling state monad
acts and model cent sourcing dependency
injection and so on and so on
interpreter capabilities 13 different
ways in all and this is a little bit
scary because that gives me about four
minutes per topic so this is how I feel
I've done a similar tool if you actually
find this still interesting believe or
not I have another talk on functional
design patterns same kind of thing lots
of lots of stuff very very quickly light
I've got I already used up a minute and
a half time to get cracking
alright so turtle graphics you should be
familiar with this with your knots the
concert is you have a turtle it's
pointing in a particular direction it
moves around and as it moves around it
draws lines that's basically it so the
turtle API that I'm going to work with
basically has four functions or four
unit operations move a certain distance
in a straight line turn some sort of
angle left to right
put the pen up put the pen down if the
pen is down then it's going to draw -
the penis off it won't draw and that's
basically it so how can we have thirteen
different implementations of this
particular API let's see let's start
with the object or in turtle and I have
a little bell here
to remind me to keep going fast like
object a turtle in an object winter
turtle data and the behavior combined
into one object of course oo turtle is a
tootle and if you didn't know what that
is so an early turtle you have a turtle
sauce and you have a client that calls
it now the turtle needs to keep track of
where it is on this canvas it needs to
know its position you need to know which
angle it's pointing that need to know
where the pen is up or down so there's
some turtle state associated with this
turtle and in the ellow model the turtle
state is inside the turtle and it's
mutable you can't you don't have access
to them as a client so I call the turtle
and it updated state I call the turtle
again updated state so let's look at the
code here is a beginning of a turtle
class in F sharp and here's the three
different things you need to keep track
of the position the angle and the state
a couple of things to point out first of
all there's a mutable key word so an F
sharp things are mutable by default so
if you want this to be mutually have to
use the mutable key word secondly I'm
using this degrees annotation and that's
part of the F sharp units of measure and
what you can do is you can take a number
and annotate it with some sort of
measurements like in this case degrees
and why did I do that so I didn't get
the mixup in radians so you know you
want to separate you know kilometres and
inches or milliseconds and seconds units
and measure ago a of doing that in this
case not only does it stop me
accidentally passing in radians but it's
the documentation so it says you know
it's obviously the done passing in
degrees they're not radians
all right the move method Sotomayor I
have a pic of distance I want to move
I'm going to log it I'm going to start
with the start position I'm going to
calculate the new position this distance
that this angle started in here that
gives me an end position if the pen is
take this down I'm going to draw from
the start position to the intention and
then I'm going to update the state this
backward pointing arrow is the
assignment operator in F sharp different
from equality because the only you only
need it when you have mutable
because I have to move methods the turn
method is very similar I want to turn a
vertical angle so I'm going to log it
I'm going to calculate a new angle using
some sort of formula and then I'm going
to update the state with a new angle the
pen up things very similar log it's
update the state log it's update the
state so that's our four methods
implemented in an LOC aisle so from the
caller's point of view is just really
obvious you basically create a turtle
you ask you to move a distance you ask
it a turn
you ask you to move a distance you ask
you to turn and so on and so forth and
in this case you end up where you
started with so you flew on a triangle
so let's actually look at some code so
this is the F sharp interactive so I'm
going to create a canvas for the turtle
going to go here's the turtle move a
certain distance turn move move again
turn move move again and you can see not
only is it drawing on the canvas but I'm
also outputting the log down here at the
bottom so that's just to prove it's the
real code it's not just a fake
presentation here not like so advantages
and disadvantage of our well the
advantage really big advantages it's
really familiar to most people that's
probably the main advantage there's
quite a lot of disadvantages to me the
biggest disadvantages is its stateful
it's a black box it's like I call this
thing but I don't get any response it
does some stuff but when you know what's
doing because I can't see inside it it's
hard to test because I have to you know
I can't really just like put it in a
position I have to like move it to this
thing setting up test is hard you can't
really compose them if I want to have a
- turtle thing I have to create a whole
new class which holds two turtles and
you know epoxy the methods down and so
on and so far in this one we've got some
hard-coded dependencies with hard coding
the logging technique in the hard coding
the canvas now we can get rid of that
using dependency injection and I'll talk
about that later on
ok number two abstract data turtle so
this technique goes all the way back to
the 70s this is 300 and in this
technique the data is separate from the
behavior so we have a data structure
again it's all the stuff is mutable but
the difference is it's a private data
structure the only person who only thing
that can change this data is the turtle
functions so as its annotate from from
the coolest one of us and a pig pig of
structure and again I have this behavior
I have these are now static methods or
functions in a module each function now
needs the state to be passed in because
it's static so this explicit state
management and again to use it I create
a turtle and I do the same thing as
before except each time now I have to
pass this turtle in by hands that's the
same same idea ok so what are the pros
and cons of this technique which is old
and low well the advantage is really
simple to implement and one of the
advantages actually now is that you
can't do inheritance so you can't
actually use object-oriented techniques
so if you think that inheritance is sort
of an anti-pattern now and the
composition is better than the heritance
this technique forces you to use
completion so that might be what you
want this is I introduced the same as in
oh oh it's stateful it's a black box
it's hard to set up it started test
right next functional turtle so in a
functional turtle this state is
immutable other than that is very
similar to the abstract data turtle um
because the state is immutable the
client or the caller has to create the
state pass the inter function and get a
new state back and then get that state
pass intersection and get the new state
back so the client is now very much
involved in managing the state
which it wasn't with our methods and the
design is very similar
we now have an immutable turtle States
we don't have to have an immutable
keyword anymore and because it's
immutable we can make it public it's not
a problem if someone accesses these
properties because they can't mess them
they can't change them the same thing we
have these four functions now we pass
the state into each function but in
addition we return the state so that's
the big difference between this one and
the one where the state is immutable
so this very much is even more explicit
now so to use this code we basically
start with initial state we'll call it
x0 we pass that in and that gives us
state 1 sorry state 1 we pass the
internet get to state 2 we pass in state
2 and it gives us state 3 and so on and
so forth so it's all very explicit it's
all very nice but it's kind of ugly you
know it's kind of annoying to pass the
state around like this is there a way we
can make this nicely looking and the
answer's yes
and that relies on the fact that every
in a functional world every turtle every
function has one input one output so if
we have two functions and we want to
chain them together we can take the
output of one function and feed it as
the input to the next function and that
is how composition works and in F sharp
we typically use the piping concepts
which is their sharpest version of this
and this is very similar to UNIX pipes
you take the output of command and you
feed it as input of the next month so
with pipes code would like this start
with initial States we pipe it into the
MU function we take the output of MU
function we pipe it into the turn
function set the output the turn
function we pipe it into the move
function take the out of that and so on
and so forth
so this vertical bar with angle bracket
that is F sharps pipe operator it's not
a vertical bar because the political
bias is reserved for something else
right so what's the pros and cons well
because everything is immutable it's a
lot easier to reason about I know I know
exactly what's going in and what's
coming out there's no black box I mean
obviously it's doing stuff but I can see
what it's doing because I get the state
coming out the other end so it's really
easy to test this way I can just if I
wanted to start in a particular corner I
just set the initial state to be in that
corner and as we've seen the functions
are composable so will it use the glue
in the other because they have no global
state the downside is that the client
has to keep track of the state and again
we have these hard-coded dependencies
and in a bit I'll talk about how you can
do sort of the functional equivalent of
a dependency injection next the states
monad so what happens if the states if
though if the thing is a bit more
complicated so let's say we have our
turtle and it hits the wall and it can't
go any further now we want to return
something to the caller that says
something went wrong so one way we can
do this is just return the actual
distance moves as opposed to what you
requested you wanted to move 10 units
and you actually only moved 5 units so
we now need to return for example a pair
with a new state and as part of the pair
the actual distance moves so here's the
usage example we start with initial
state we pass that into the move and we
get a pair back to the actual distance
and then state one if the actual
distance is less and what we want is
then it fails and we're going to turn
the turtle and so on and if the actual
distance was correct then the first move
succeeded and we try again and we get
another actual distance and this is
really ugly right I mean it's all very
explicit it's all very no clear what's
going on but passing the state around is
horrible and unfortunately we can't do
the piping technique because the output
is now this pair it's not the individual
state that we can just pass into the
next function
so how can we keep keep track of the
state when we have a situation like this
so we've got what we're going to do is
we're going to take the turtle function
and go through a series of
transformations and turn it into
something which is more tractable
something which is more composable so
the total function we have right now has
two inputs and two outputs they're one
of the inputs is that turtle States and
the other input is their runtime input
the distance to move or the angles of
turn or whatever it is the two outputs
one of the outputs is the the new turtle
state and the other output is the output
of the function the actual distance
moved or the actual distance turned or
whatever it is so how can we turn this
into something we can work with well the
first thing is we can turn it into a two
step function of the input returns
another function so lower than having a
two parameter function we have a one
parameter function that returns another
one parameter function and that's called
carrying and that's the fundamental part
of functional programming in F sharp you
get that for free so in fact the
function is automatically like this and
if we have this curried model we can
actually think of the turtle function as
returning a new function so I pass in
the distance I want to move and I don't
just get a new state I get a new
function and so we're going to take this
function here like returning another
function standard practice that it's
kind of ugly we're going to take this
function we're going to put a wrapper
around it and we're going to call it
States all right so the state is really
just a wrapper around a function but
what we've done now is we have a
function with one input and one output
and now we can chain these together we
can't chain them together directly we
can change together using a special
technique which are not going to go into
if you want to know more about it I have
a talk called the monads to talk which
is all about the state monad but
assuming that we can compose these
functions together what we can do is you
can create a special thing called a
state expression of state computation
expression that's this little State
thing in in red there
and it's kind of like a special block a
special code blocks inside the code
block the state is been managed behind
the scenes so when I write this codes
here you know move and then turn move
again all that code the state has
actually been threaded through that code
without me having to do anything so this
code looks much nicer it looks like the
original code we had looks like
imperative code but it's not it's
actually stateless immutable code that
we had originally made nice-looking by
this state expression and we'll see a
lot of this in the next couple of slides
as well so the state thing fitted to the
scenes is a really nice feature now this
is a very common technique and most
functional programming languages have
equivalent of this so Haskell has do
notation Scala has for comprehension
they're all related to monads the extra
up computation expressions are kind of
related to monads advantages so it looks
like imperative code it looks like is
this the state that's actually changing
but it isn't it's just immutable behind
the scenes but the nice thing is even
though it's got this complicated stuff
the functions are still composable you
can still glue functions together
downside much harder to implement kind
of and it's tricky to use and practice
next no ice our handling so let's say we
want to handle errors in a different way
let's say when we hit the edge of the
wall rather than returning the actual
distance we're going to say sorry you
made a mistake that's a failure so how
can we handle that in a functional way
what we want to do is have the function
return two different possibilities these
are it succeeded or it fails so if it
succeeded I get a new turtle state back
and if it fails I'm going to return an
error message saying you know you went
out of bounds or something so how can we
model a function that returns two
choices so it's not the two values what
you know together it's like one or the
other one
so in F sharp you would model this using
a choice type like this and a choice
type
is kind of like inheritance or the lack
of subclassing you basically have two
possibilities and they're mutually
exclusive it's either a success or its
failure if it success there's some
information associated with that if it's
a failure there's some information such
as you've got to and I call these choice
types technical word is some types in F
sharp
they're called discriminated unions
they're all pretty much the same thing
really really nice feature
unfortunately most object language did
not have anything like this very very
powerful so let's look at how we would
implement the move function using this
result so we want to move a certain
distance so we calculate the new
position we draw the line let's do the
error handling if the actual distance
moves is not what we wanted then we're
going to return a failure if it was what
we want is we're going to say it's
successful and we're going to return the
new state the state with the updated the
position so again there's two possible
choices for the outputs now because
there's two possible choices when I
actually call this code I have to test
and see which one it is so let's look at
how that works so there's my initial
total state I'm going to move and I'm
going to get one of these results so I
have to test is it a success or failure
and I do that with pattern matching so
if it's successful that's great I'm
going to try and move again
I get another results I'm going to see
what's the second result successful
failure if it's successful I'm done if
it was a failure I've put an error
message and then I also need to handle
the case where the first one was a
failure so again this is all very nice
and explicit but it again is kind of
ugly to keep track of all these to be
testing these special cases all the time
can we make it simpler yes
so let's avoid some yuckiness and create
a new kind of expression this is a
result computation expression and again
it's a special kind of block which
handles all the failure cases so if
there's a success it keeps going so like
this if the moon was successful it will
do this next step and if that was
successful it will do the next step and
if that
successful to do the next up if there is
any failures along this line it will
basically go to the bottom that kind of
bypass all this code and go directly to
the you know bottom of the code so very
similar to how we do the state the same
kind of thing
all right there's a result expression so
again we've turned something kind of
nicely looking into something which is
manageable now in this code we still
have this states hang we keep passing
the state to every single function what
we can do is combine we can take the
state one and the result one and combine
them into a combined expression so we're
going to create a result state
expression both of them and now when we
do this we've got rid of the state as
well there's no state in any of this
code so this code looks really
imperative it looks like just like the
object-oriented code really it's like
move here move here turn here move here
but unlike the objetive object-oriented
code there's error handling built in and
there's state management built in so
there you go that's quite nice so we've
got this easily with these computation
expressions in F sharp for a very nice
way of hiding all this nastiness so what
we've got here we've got explicit errors
we're not varying exceptions we don't
have to look in the documentation to see
if it's going to be a failure not
for example the pen up and the pen down
might not return a failure but the move
function we can tell it returns up here
because it's going to return this type
which is either successful failure but
when we write the code it looks like the
happy part of code it doesn't look like
we've got all this nasty error handling
there's nothing about handling
exceptions or fly catch or anything it's
all it's all handle for me downsize
again harder to implement and harder to
use I have a whole talk on this topic
too which is the railway oriented
programming talk which you might have
heard of alright next a sink turtle
this is like five and a half this is
sort of a bonus thing so it's actually
thirteen and a half ways of looking at a
turtle what happens if the turtle is
actually a real low block turtle and you
actually are sending you know remote
signals to it to get something to happen
so the turtle is going to be a sync
thing like you're going to have to send
a thing and wait for response so how
would we handle that well very similar
we have an async move now with async
equation you do something and then you
have to have a callbacks like when it
finishes doing what it's that it's going
to call you back
so it's going to call you back with the
new state all right and when it's called
me back I'm going to make another move
and then when it's finished doing that
it's going to call me back with the new
States and I'll make another move when
it's done we'll call you back for the
new state so this is a very common
pattern when you have async code when
you have another callbacks you get this
thing called the Pyramid of doing
because it ends up going further and
further out how can we make this easier
we've got all these nasty callbacks we
really don't want to see these are not
in our code if we can help it is their
way of getting rid of them so this is a
tripity tripity yucks
callback stuff very nasty yes async
expression again we have another
computation expression and what this one
does is it hides the callbacks behind
the scenes so when I write the code I
say move async but I don't have to worry
there's no callback basically the
callback happens automatically and then
I move async again and I move away sync
again and the ACE again it looks like
some normal codes that the async
callbacks handle behind the scenes so
there's a pattern here we've got the
state thing we've got the result things
or the async thing they're all the same
kind of pattern and that pan is the
famous M word like monads so monads is
the commonality between these patterns
so let's review what we've done so far
we're using composition a lot with
chaining functions together we haven't
created any new objects every time we
wanted to do something we've got
explicit state management we've got no
mutation we've got explicit
showing any exceptions all this
explicitness is great it makes it really
easy to the test it makes it easy to
reason about the downside is it looks
really ugly but we have techniques to
make that easy to work with we can hide
these state and the errors and the
callbacks behind the scenes using
monadic composition these computation
expressions alright next
okay batch processing now in all
examples so far the caller has been
managing the state and it's painful
basically even even with all these
computation expressions it's still
painful too many state how can we have
it sort of caller avoids managing state
altogether well the first technique
we'll look at is just a batch processing
what we're going to do is create a bunch
of commands and send it to a batch
processor so from the clients point of
view I create a command and I create a
whole bunch of lists of kelan's and I
send it to the batch runner and the
batch runner is going to loop over all
the commands and run them in turn each
one in turn actually calling the turtle
functions and it's part of its loop it's
going to be keeping track of the states
so the clients no longer have to keep
track of the states this batch processor
is going to keep track of the state so
that's nice from the clients point of
view it's much nicer but we have a
problem which is these commands our data
and our API is not data its functions so
how can we turn our API which of these
four functions how can we turn this into
a data structure that we can send down
the wire to the batch process well it's
quite simple we use another choice type
and basically for each function in the
API we create a choice so there's a
function called move which has a
distance parameter we're going to create
a choice case which has a distance thing
associated with it the turn is going to
have an angle associated with it the pen
up doesn't have any data associated with
it the pen down doesn't have an inflator
associated with it so we now a turtle
command which mirrors the
the total api except it's pure data this
can be serialized and put on the wire so
choice pipe to the for the win again so
here's the planks and code again here's
my list of commands right now these look
like function calls that it's actually
beta when I say move 100 I'm actually
creating a data structure and when I say
turn 120 I'm creating a data structure
so this is actually a list of data
records right I take this list and I
send it to the batch processor and it
runs more than once so from the clients
point of view that's very nice no state
anywhere but this it means this thing
about being data is really important
we'll come back to it later now on the
batch runners side it's going to have to
execute this data structure and how
we're going to do that well very
straightforward but each case is going
to execute a particular turtle function
so for the move case it's going to move
the turtle for the angled turn case it's
going to turn the turtle and so on and
so forth and notice that in the inside
it's got this States excusing track of
the states all right state is passed in
the beginning and it comes out the other
end so the the overall implementation
for the run is going to say okay start
with the initial States for each command
in the list of commands you're going to
loop through them you're going to
execute the command for each one that's
going to create a new state and then
after you've loop through all the
commands you're going to have the final
States and that is what you turn back to
the caller now this is basically a for
loop we'll in these but in f-sharp that
you wouldn't actually bother to write
this because actually this is built-in
function called fold all function
languages will have this as part of
their library in c-sharp
it's the link function link to aggregate
very useful I basically would not like
your own don't like your own iterations
learn to use the collection function
switch already built into the library so
this is list fold will be seeing fold
again shortly
all right so what's the advantages and
disadvantages of the batch processing
well first of all it's completely
decoupled because I'm sending data I
have absolutely no idea what the
implementation is that's really nice
that's really decoupled it's a lot
easier than working with monads the
state is much much easier
the downside is spatula entered right I
think I'm had to do all the commands at
once and the other disadvantage is
there's no control flow like if the
first command fails I don't I can't
choose and say well if it fails I want
to do this if it doesn't fail under this
it's like here's a bunch of commands
it's fire-and-forget and then I just
have to take it all or nothing so that's
the downside but if you can get away
with it that's really nice
all right next EXO model so the actor
model is quite similar to the batch
model except it's sort of like a
real-time version of the batch model so
in the actor model I have a command
exactly the same kind of Kumada years
before but this time I'm going to put it
on a cue the actor is basically a little
message loop that weeds things off the
cue processes the commands and then goes
back and goes around the loop again so
again all the state is kept track of in
the actor the client doesn't have to
keep track of the state the turtle
doesn't keep track of the state the
status would have been in between - so
let's look at the code so all-access
have a loop the link takes the initial
turtle state that comes in we also then
read a command from the message queue we
create a new state how do we create the
new state by testing the command if it's
a move move move the turtle and so on we
run the command the same way we did
exactly the same way we did before we
get a new state and then the difference
is we now take that new state and we
feed it back into the top we take the
new state and we loop again it's a
recursive loop and then that loop will
then block waiting for another command
on the message queue so the actor model
and the batch model are you can share a
lot of code between the two models all
right so very similar that except you
have now this recursive loop which
blocks each time two
so again from the caller's point of
views really easy to use I create a
turtle and I post a message now because
it's a queue I post the move message
opposed to current message I post a move
message but unlike the batch model every
time I post the message the turtle
responds pretty much straight away right
so it's not exactly we all find but it's
you know it's responsive to what I do I
don't have to wait until I've finished
all the commands all right so pros and
cons of the actor model again very
decouples I have no idea what the
implementation is I'm just sending it
data again simpler than working with a
state monad downsides kind of lots of
boilerplate associated axes not quite as
easy to understand but I think you know
if you're managing States as one of my
favorite ways of managing state if I
have musical state like this next event
sourcing rights so events sourcing the
diagrams are going to get more more
complicated as we go on so we started
with with getting past the simple ones
on getting more complicated and the
eventual thing issue really is how do we
persist the states between ones so the
accent model is if your program crashes
you've just lost everything so we want
to persist the states so that if the
acts of crashes we can low it we can
start off low easy we pick up where we
left off or if we want to start up and
another server so it goes down we want
to run another server we can scale out
whether it's nice to persist it so we
could just still it straight in a
database but one of the things about
function program is that you might want
to have an immutable database a database
that you can't just update you can only
append to so if you want to append to
something you just it's a different
design altogether so what we're going to
do is we're going to append to the
database to the event store and events
and an event is basically he's a diff
between before the command and art of
command and so I like what changed as a
result of running this command
so we get a command in from the clan
handler and we're going to we have this
event still which has a list of previous
events we're going to lead the previous
events into memory we're going to
recreate the state by by applying all
these events and now we have the states
that it was before the commands we then
execute the commands and that actually
talks to the turtle and does all the
work and then when the command is
finished the output of the command is a
bunch of a new events and these new
events get put back into the event store
and so the new events represent what
changed between before the commodity
model command because again when we get
the next command we're going to take
these new events and read them up as
part that event history to recreate the
state so that's basically how events or
thing works um so one of the things is
what is the difference between a command
and an event an event sourcing seems to
be a tricky question sometimes but let's
actually have a look so here's our
turtle command we've got our four
different choices here the command is
what you want to have happen it might
not actually happen I say I want to move
here and I want to move the assistance
but if I hit the wall it might not work
I might not I've actually moved anything
I'll you know I might have only moved
faster to past as much so just because
you want it to happen doesn't mean it
actually happens now the event is what
actually happens so when I have an event
everything's going to be in the past
tense I actually moved this distance and
I actually turned this angle and I
actually move the pen up and down and
you can see that the the event is not
quite the same as the command I didn't
have to be one-to-one correspondence and
you can store some extra data here so
you know in the command I wanted to move
a certain distance but in the moved
event I can keep track of what the start
position and the end position was as
well because that's kind of helpful or I
can keep track of not only what the
angle I want to discern but what the
actual final angle was so this is what
actually happened and it's always past
tense and again if we compare it with a
command we can see it's subtly different
so it's the events that we saw in the
event stall in the database
it's not the commands that's why it's
got the event sourcing so there's two
important parts of the event sourcing
well we've seen how to actually apply a
command but let's talk about how do we
apply an event we have a historical
event we have this particular state and
we want to you know that I say the event
is sort of a diff between the previous
state and the new state so if it's a
moved events we say well the state was
over here and now the new state is over
here if it was a turned events we can
say well the original you know the state
is now this new final angle and that's
one of the reasons we can store this
extra data in the state which makes some
of this handling much easier notice that
we are not calling the turtle okay this
is purely an in-memory state changing
operation we are not caught there's no
i/o it's all pure okay
so this is one of the key functions that
you need to implement within the bench
sourcing model all right no side effects
very important nothing happens
we're just looping through the things
and modifying the state to get back to
what it was before the command happens
and then to actually handle the command
then very simple we load all the events
from the event store that gives us our
event history we create the state before
the command by losing for all the events
and applying that apply event thing so
that's again with using the list fold
codex which is basically the for loop
and then now we have the states that it
was just before the commands which would
have been the same as if it been using
actor model something we have the state
in memory we apply the command we
execute the command that changes the
states and it creates some new events
and then these new events are then
written back into the event stall so
again very critical that the when you're
rebuilding the state there's no side
effects when you're executing them and
that's where the side effects happen
that's where you actually move move the
turtle
all right pros and cons of event
sourcing again very decouples from
implantation stateless what's nice is it
supports the replay of events if the
business logic changes you have the
history of everything that happened to
have an audit trail for free many nice
features about event sourcing this is
why it's sort of trendy right now
unfortunately is more complex to manage
and when you have like a history you
have to kind of keep the integrity of
the history so you need to have like
versioning of the events the old events
might be slightly different from the new
events
it just becomes a lot trickier than just
managing the snapshot of the current
state but for many situations it's worth
it Mike's next stream processing so
steam screen processing is like event
sourcing even more but even more so so
the diagram is getting even more
complicated with the stream processing
you basically have these event streams
you're going to have a much of event
streams coming into you going to pick
and choose which events you want to
handle some of them are interesting some
of them not interesting to you're going
to select you're going to do a filter
and then once you've got the events that
you're interested in you turn them into
command you execute the command just
like we did and we you know just the
same as with the event sourcing thing
we've put the data back in the event
store and that generates new events
right we run the command that generates
new events which is manhandled by the
next person down the line so this is why
it's a stream each little thing is
processing a stream events coming in
doing some work generating new events
and that becomes a stream of events
going out for the next person so that's
that's the concepts let's look at how it
would work with the turtle so one of the
things is that you can separate the
decision-making process from the state
changing process rather than putting
everything in the command handler like
you would with a basic event sourcing
you can say well oh I'm going to do is
trigger an event and then you can decide
what to do with that event that event
might be important to you or I might not
be important but I don't get too precise
I'll let you decide and that gives you a
lot more flexibility so let's say in the
turtle situation we're going to have the
command Handler and all it does is
update the turtle state it just figures
out where the turtle is on the canvas
but it doesn't actually move the turtle
it doesn't log anything how what you do
with that information is for the
downstream processes to decide so for
example we might have an audit processor
so every time you do something it's very
important that we keep track of every
turtle commands because it's a
high-security turtle we want to make
sure that nobody is messing with it the
canvas processor might actually move the
turtle around the camera so we might
have a physical turtle robot that
physically moves the robot let's say we
want to keep track of how many miles the
turtles moves because we want to keep
track of whether the battery's about to
run out
let's call this a distance processor so
three different kinds of business logic
all using same event stream as input so
let's actually look at some real codes
go back to school code here right where
are we screen questions
okay here's our vent process so the
audit processor this is the handler so
if it moved we're going to write that
message out if it turned we're going to
write a message out if it's you know
change we're going to wait a message out
and then what we're going to do is start
with all the other event stream as the
input and for each particular event the
observable we're just going to call that
function so that's our auditing
processor give that one out of the way
now here's the canvas processor and this
one it's only going to draw on the
canvas so it doesn't it only needs to
care about moves events so I'm going to
have a move filter so I'm going to
filter out everything other than moved
events so again I start with all events
but I choose the move events only and
then I just handle those by actually
drawing on the canvas which is very
secure there so let's create one of
those and let's do a distance traveled
processor so all this one is just going
to keep track of how much you want the
distances just add it to the total
distance so far and then the end is just
going to print out the distance traveled
so again I'm only interested in moved
events so start with all events choose
the moved ones only and accumulate the
distance and then print it out so let's
do that
alright so there's our three processes
so here's our event stream there's our
three screen processes let's open up the
canvas let's handle the whoops I need to
know what's wrong here
I need to cancel this out dragon I think
it's wrong
there we go so I've moved 100 and then
I'm going to turn now notice when I
moved 100 I got that audit I also got
the distance traveled when I turned I
didn't get anything happen except the
audit when I move again that I got the
audit I got the distance traveled and I
also got the canvas changing and I do it
again I do it again so now the distance
travelled is 300 I've got the audits and
I've got the canvas all three going at
the same time so there you go it's quite
nice and what's what's nice is I'll have
a new kind of business logic I can just
plug another event processor in
downstream I don't have to change the
original turtle State processor so it's
got decoupling of the business logic
which is quite a nice feature so the
advantages same as the eventual thing
I've got replay history I've got
decoupling but the state and the
business object can be as separate as
you like and you have multiple consumers
of the events so this is very micro
service friendly basically a lot of
people use this kind of architecture of
doing micro services this is Vantage's
complex it's getting kind of hard to
program if you don't need it I wouldn't
do this it's just sort of fun toy demo
you know use it if you need to use it
but I wouldn't do it just because it's
trendy okay so what have we got so far
we've got conscious decoupling using
data types
rather than functions we're passing
we've got these immutable data stores
and we're storing event history rather
than the current States next
dependency injection right so if we had
an object-oriented class we wouldn't
want them to use at a particular canvas
implementation we want to pass it in we
want to pass in the logger so what we do
is we create an interface and I canvas
and an ilogger and we inject those
interfaces into the turtle class in the
constructor and then the move method
would use the canvas and the logger the
turn method would use just the logo and
the pen duck would use just the logo and
so on that's low dependency injection
I'm sure you're all familiar with this
again if I wanted to decouple the client
from the turtle i would have an i total
interface and the client would be
injected with the isle and when it
wanted to draw a triangle it would use
the i turtle rather than the particular
implementation so i'm not going to do a
demo because we've got enough time so
the advantages if people are familiar
with this but this design just is quite
a few first of all you have these
unintentional dependencies so in this
model I passed in a canvas but only the
moon function the move method need to
the canvas return function method didn't
need it but it could accidentally access
it so there's a potential bug there or
just even the potential dependency where
you've got this thing depending on
something didn't need to depend on and
often when you use interfaces they're
not fine-grained anyone who's used a you
know repository interface or a data
access layer kind of thing if you find
that you know you've got this customer
database thing and it like get a
customer update a customer insert a
customer delete the customer change the
customers password all these kinds of
things and typically you know sometimes
you end up with things with like 40
methods on it you only need one or two
of these methods you only need like
fetch for customer so do you really want
to be able to delete the customer or
change the customers passwords when all
you want to do is fetch the custom from
the database so it's very easy if it
interfaces to glow which is why you have
things like the interface segregation
principle those various I you know
guidelines to help you avoid doing that
the other thing is when you have these
deeply nested dependencies you often
need a hell
/ lively like a OC container or
something to help you manage all the
injection logic right so let's look at
functional dependency injection so in
the functional style there is no class
so every single function needs to have
its dependencies passed into it so the
move function needs to have the login
function and the draw function passed in
the turn function needs to have the
login function passed in and so on so
forth now the nice thing about this is
that the turn function can't possibly
depend on drawing on canvas because it's
not one of the parameters so instantly
we have this nice kind of decoupling you
know you're not going to get accidental
use between two different functions but
now we have a problem because and so by
the way these are functions we're
passing and these are not interfaces
with every single thing that the thing
needs to do is passed in as a separate
parameter so now we have a what we had
originally was a move function that just
you passed in the distance so now we
have these extra parameters that we have
class in a logging function we have to
pass in a drawing function it's kind of
awkward I don't want have to pass in a
win over every single time but we can go
back to the carrying concepts we can say
this is actually a two parameter
function that returns a new function so
what we're going to do is pass in just
these first two parameters and not the
last one and that gives us a new
function and the new function has the
the login function and the drawing
function sort of baked in to this new
function and from the clients point of
view it looks like the original function
it just has this one parameter where you
pass in the distance that I want to move
so it's it's kind of like it's kind of
like they've been injected that's from
that kind of course point of view you
know I'm back to where was originally
it's quite nice so if we look at the
implementation for how moves works we're
now passing in the log info and the draw
these are now two function parameters so
this is now a lot of more parameters
similarly if I want to turn I have to
pass in the log as a function parameter
but when I use it I basically create a
new function by passing in the first two
routers now here I'm create a new
function by passing in just below the
parameter so these parameters being
passed in this is the partial
application technique and what's less
now is this function which is just what
I need just the basic move function so
if I'm using it in actually the client
I'm drawing some stuff I can just say
take the turtle State you know move 50
and then turn 120 and I don't have to
keep passing in the loader and the
canvas over and over and over again it's
kind of baked into the function so there
we go and I'm not going to do a demo
because I'm short of time so the nice
thing about the functional model is
again everything's explicit I pass in a
plan to every single dependency has to
be passed in as a parameter and all the
dependencies are passed in is individual
functions not as interfaces so you can't
get this thing where you have 40 methods
being passed in and so that's a really
good counter force to having too many
dependencies so you don't need to have a
little thing don't have 40 methods on
your interface because you're having 40
parameters and that's really ugly you
know straight away that something's
wrong with your code you're going to be
refactoring it straight away when you
have 40 parameters so you basically have
a natural counter veiling you know
downhill the easy the path of least
resistance just has fewer parameters so
you kind of get the ISP for free
interface Federation principle you don't
have to like hard code it you know our
special code of view the other thing is
you don't need a special library you
don't need IFC container it's built in
this thing of using partial application
is a fundamental functional program
techniques it's like something just
learns very beginning what's the
downside I don't think there are any I
think it was actually really nice
technique I use all the time and I can't
think of anything wrong with it so there
you go
all right next we're down to the last
two the interpreter like so we have our
turtle api we have our four functions
like this and it looks quite nice but
there's some coupling
going on again example this is the kind
of basic API but let's say we want to
have the results be you know we don't
wanna do the error handling thing so
they're going to return results all
right so that's without the result and
that's with the results and they say
well that's nice but now we've decided
to make it a sink so now we need to be
an async result okay so before and after
every time we do this we wake the caller
anyone who's calling this code is now
broken they had to work with a sinks
rather than what they had before now
normally that's quite a good thing it's
kind of nice to break the caller it's
nicely you know you know that when it
composite from the work so if it's not
compiling it you know it's a nice
reminder that you something's changed in
the API but it's still kind of annoying
is there a way to avoid this and the
answer is yes the answer is addy couple
using data structures again um we saw
this before with the batch processing
and the actor model and so on if we can
turn this into a data structure we can
completely decoupled ourselves from
actually what's going on behind the
scenes with us a sink or whatever the
only problem is that we can't manage
control flow as we saw with a batch
command there's no control flow this
time we want to deal with the control
flow so how can we do control flow well
if you think about it what we're going
to do is we're going to create an
interpreter for the data structure so I
am going to send a data structure which
I'm going to call a program like it's
going to say I want you to move the
interpreter is going to interpret that
some way whether it moves a turtle or
just there's something I don't care
under my business how it actually works
it's going to return the response the
move was once like the actual distance
moves now I can then make a decision
based on that response like what am I
going on our turn and we're going to
move again either way I'm going to
create a new program okay
so here's the next step and say it's
going to be a turn the interpreters
gonna interpret that step it's going to
return the response for that thing and
based on that response I'm going to make
another decision and I'm going to create
another data structure which contains
the information that I want to send to
the interpreter and so on and back and
forth so you get this back and forth
during the client and the interpreter so
how do we write this in code this one's
getting a bit more complicated so bear
with me again we have four cases one for
each function in the API but it's
getting ugly so let's let me show you
how it works
first of all we have the distance which
sort of it for the move case we have the
input parameter to the interpreter and
this is like this is the distance I want
you to move ok the interpreter is going
to come back with a response which in
this case is another distance the
distance actually moved okay so that's
the output for the interpreter and then
I need to make a decision based on that
response and I'm going to create a new
turtle program which I give back to the
interpreter again ok so that's basically
the next step for the interpreter so
each of these things generates a new
program all right so this is series if I
want to do a turn it's the same thing I
passed in the angle I don't get any
response and I create another step and
so on so this is the fundamental model
of what we're going to do now the
problem with this is that each step
returns another turtle program and so on
ad infinitum so it goes on for infinity
right so we're going to have to have
another step which I'm going to call
stop that's the end of the interpreter
so this is a new case needed that wasn't
in the original design so let's see how
we actually would use it from a science
point of view so if I want to do a
triangle I'm going to set this data
structure now this is not a command this
is the data structure and the first side
of the data structure is what I'm
sending you the second part is a
function which is given the response ok
I'm going to give you another program so
it's almost like a callback so there's a
continuation you give me this response I
will give you another program another
programming on give you is a turn ok
you're going to give me a response back
and I'm going to give you another
program which is a move you're going to
give me a sponge back I'm going to give
you a turn again and so on and so forth
and then finally I'm going to say ok I'm
done you can stop now so this is how you
would draw a triangle using this
approach
ugly again all these continuations is
their way to get rid of them yes though
is yes we can get rid of them
how can we get rid of them we use the
same thing with it before we create a
special expression that computation
expression that hides it we've seen this
trick many times before so we're going
to call a turtle program expression and
inside the turtle program we don't have
to worry about these continuations that
get hand or sores behind the scenes so
the program again looks like an
imperative kind of program move here
turning a movie or turn here but this is
data ok this is not moving a turtle this
is purely a data structure it's an
abstract syntax tree if you think so now
I need to interpret this data so I have
this set of instructions I've created
the turtle program I can have many
different interpreters for the same
program so let's talk about a normal
winter that'll be the turtle interpreter
so for each case I need to handle it so
if it's a stop case I'm done if it's the
move case I'm going to move the turtle
I'm going to get the actual distance
back that gets fed into the next step
and now I have in the next program and I
basically call myself again I loop back
recursively and call the interpret
function again but now with the next
step in the program if it's a turn I
turn the turtle I get the response I get
the next step in the program and then I
call myself again recursively with the
next steps this is they look thanks we
need to understand this very way but you
can see it's not that many lines of code
like no turbot is not a hard ok so
moving the turtle executing next step
calling myself recursively if I want to
have a distance interpreter same kind of
thing except all I care about is moving
so if you move I'm just going to
accumulate the distance and call myself
again and if it's a I dislike no change
or so I just call me the next step
alright so let me see if I can do a
quick demo of this
[Music]
yeah interpreters distance here we go
here's the code for that so here's the
draw triangle program when interpret as
a turtle there's the initial state I'm
going to set up my canvas and now
interpret the program so the program
says turn move turn move to move the
light so that's one interpretation now I
can take the same program okay exactly
the same program but this time I'm going
to interpret the data structure as a
distance thingy
I need initial distance which is zero
and I'm going to interpret the program
as a distance changing thing and all it
does is print the answer here's the
total distance moved was three
hundredths so this is really nice I
really really decoupled the client from
the entropy note from behind the scenes
okay the Vantage is completely decoupled
nothing but API no implantation you can
do some neat tricks with optimization so
for example if I have free moves in a
row in the in the data structure I can
collapse them into one single move so
that might save time on network you know
thing the disadvantage is really kind of
complex and it really only works with a
set of limited operations some good
examples of this approach this is called
the free monad approach as well
Twitter's stitch library Facebook's
axial library they use this technique
all right so I've just got a few minutes
left last one all right so I'm just
going to go a few minutes over I hope
you'll be allowed time capabilities okay
so the last one this is a general thing
about calling any API if I call an API
sometimes it fails okay and I try to
call it again and sometimes it fails
again and it just can't do that and it's
quite annoying if you've got an API and
it doesn't really give you any guidance
on how to call it you have to know how
the API
in order to call it especially and
that's quite annoying so rather than
having a can I tell you what you can't
do you call it in a so I can't do that
you call it so I can't do that
one thing what you can't do why not say
what I can do okay so this is what I
call the capability based API so the
capability is kind of like a key if you
have the key you can open the door if
you don't have the key you can't open
the door all right so I'm going to model
capabilities kind of like a key so I
make a call to the API and instead of
just give me a result the API gives me
back a bunch of keys it gives me back a
bunch of capabilities and each of those
capabilities I can choose which one of
those capabilities to use so which dorm
are going to open so okay I'm going to
pick one of those and I'm going to open
the door and it takes me into new room
and I get a bunch more capabilities
because it's like it's one of like one
of those dungeon games you know so in
the turtle thing how does this work in
the turtle world I make a move so
instead of just getting response back I
get three capabilities back you can move
you can turn you can set the pen down
for example all right so let me see I
want to move again now this time I've
moved to the edges of board and I get to
say percentage back I can't move anymore
so one of them trying to move and
getting a failure I literally do not
have the capability to move the turtle
that is not one of the functions I can
call so this is the key thing about
capability based programming now this is
the code this is the stress of data
structure basically which of the mister
functions the move function is optional
the turn function the pen up function
the pen down function these are all
always there so when i make a move i
pass in addition should I get back the
capabilities when I when I turn I pass
in an angle and I get back the
capabilities and so on and so forth so
from the caller's point of view I start
with some capabilities now what I have
to do is test do is the move function
either there so if the move function is
not there it's an error
okay but mine we try turning around and
see if the move function shows up again
if the move function is there then okay
I can use it I'm going to move but now
I've moved I have to check again and you
set of capabilities and the move
function might not be in the second set
so I ask
- the moon flexion again and if it's
nothing that I can't do the second move
and so on
so the client has to do this logical
checking whether the capabilities fail
or not so let me do a quick demo and
then I'll be done in literally a minute
so here's the initial table capabilities
and you can see there's the state of
structure and here's the move function
so it's available
so let me move and I've moved and now I
still have a move function available so
let me move again and now I've reached
the edge of the canvas I can't move
anymore and so the move function is now
null it's not available for me to use
but if I turn I get a new set of
capabilities and this time there is a
move function so I can use the loop
function again and I can keep doing that
so the capability thing is it capable if
they have kind of come and go based on
whether I can do them a lot so that's
kind of nice so what's the pros and cons
of this well the big the big advantage
to me is the client doesn't have to
duplicate the business logic in many
situations you find that the client has
to know what to do you have to
understand what the server is actually
doing in this model the client all it
does is follow what the server tells you
do says you can do this you can't do
this and it's not a thing I'll just do
that so that gives you some much better
security so for example you can't
accidentally delete a customer because
the delete capability is not given to
you you can also do clever things with
capabilities can transform them because
they're just functions you can if you
want to say a business rule you can only
use a turtle between nine and five on
weekends or something you can just take
one of those papers you can wrap it up
in another function and that function
you know adds that extra constraint that
you can only use at a certain time so
caper this is great if you're doing
complex business rules downsides really
complex and the client has to handle
this unavailable functionality which
really it should be doing anyway
all right classic example of this is
hypertext as the engine of application
state proper restful architecture is
exactly this model you get back to a
bunch of links and you follow the links
and if the links not there you can't do
it and if the link is there you can't do
it that's a really nice model all right
more on this I have a talk on this cat
slash camp on my website and that is it
so thank you very much say the slides
will be at the slash turtle directory if
you need f-sharp consulting contact us
at eff shot works if you want to know
more about F sharp including
instructions on how to download and
install it go to F sharp org so thank
you very much and I'll be available for
questions if you want